I'm Anna Taylor joy and I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm going to be talking
about my first times first thing you do
on your phone when you wake up i text
somebody that i love and i say that i'm
awaken alive on the planet just so they
don't worry about it okay first time you
knew you were famous famous is a bit of
a weird word for me I think I've had
lots of different hair colors so it's
been quite easy for people to be like oh
you look so much like the girl from blue
but with different hair and now that
I've kind of come back around to all of
them it's getting harder to do that so I
have to just kind of say that yeah no
I'm I'm that girl first dating advice
you ever got a boy told me he loved me
and I didn't feel it back and I asked my
sister if I should say it back to him
and she felt really bad for him I was
like say it but I didn't because I don't
think you should say it if you don't
mean it down it goes ago first Jane
Austen novel you read Emma but she does
have it's not a book but it's a
collection of letters that she wrote to
her sister Cassandra and that's like a
really good reader first role you really
wanted but didn't get it was my first
audition ever and as my first experience
of like rejection like true rejection
and it was to play the young Angelina
Jolie and Maleficent and it was Disney
which for me was like oh my god even
there looked nothing like her but I did
I definitely cried for a very long time
after that happened first memory from
filming a combination of like terror I
was really frightened my first day of
rehearsals cuz I just so love these like
icons of cinema come in and they were
also English and I'm like a mutt of lots
of different places and so I was just
like oh my goodness I really hope I do a
good job at this and then like pure love
when I realized that people that I was a
real fan of we're so nice and I wanted
to hang out all the time
first wild fan experience you know you
just live inside of your own head so you
don't think well you kind of know that
you're just a human being like anybody
else when people shake or cry when they
meet you you just feel really like
please turn to that it's really okay
like I'm not scary and I'm not you know
anything wild and crazy um so you have
the shaking I've never I just I kind of
just try and calm them down first time
you watch clueless sleepover
13:14 last time I watched clearly is
probably like last week like I watched
that maybe a lot that maybe first
onscreen kiss I think it was James
McAvoy in split which was an old first
kiss to have considering he's playing my
captor and I had to have my eyes open
the whole time whilst he was pretending
to be like a 9 year old boy so that was
that's pretty standard I think you know
I think everyone's had that experience
personally first TV show you remember
binge watching 8 simple rules for dating
my teenage daughter that was on at 7
o'clock every night I just loved it I
try and like stay up late to watch it
first book to movie adaptation you
remember loving ok I had the world's
biggest crush on Peter Pan like forever
just that character in that book was
just everything I'd ever wanted in my
life and then I saw Jeremy Sumpter do it
in 2003 and my heart just could not
handle it I think I watched that film
every single day for like four months
so Jeremy first job I don't even have I
got paid for it I did a modeling shoot I
can't really remember that but I think
the first job that I didn't get paid for
was basically doing anything that my
sister wanted me to do cuz I thought she
was the coolest person in the entire
world and I just wanted her to love me
so I just like would make her sandwiches
and give her massages and just just do
all of that kind of stuff first kiss as
fourteen I was on a trampoline I was
determined that I was not gonna get to
15 and not have been kissed like that
was not going to happen to me like my
life was no that was not part of the
story of my life I felt pretty good
about it afterwards I was like yeah
trampoline 14 I feel good about that in
my life story first time you were
starstruck I used to like live my life
listening to the soundtrack from beasts
of the southern wild and Dan Romer
scored that and I met him at a studio
and we had just been having like a
really nice conversation and then
halfway through I realized he was down
Roemer and I just couldn't breathe it's
like okay and then I just sort of ran
away I didn't really know what else to
do and then I met Saoirse Ronan when I
was 20 and she was a big you know Idol
for me when I was
so and I just I don't remember what I
said I don't think I was very cool I'm
gonna work on that one first scene you
filmed for Emma weird one we did the
carriage scene Josh O'Connor and I were
in this carriage that wasn't really
moving and the scene takes place like
towards the end of the film and we were
like it was really fun cuz we got to do
it a whole bunch of different ways and
Josh is just so funny that it was quite
difficult to not be laughing the whole
time when you're in such an enclosed
space with him first impressions of Bill
Nighy and Johnny Floyd on the set of
Emma well I mean bill he's the coolest
man that you will ever meet like that
just that that role is taken and that's
happened and he showed up wearing his
lounge robes it's very difficult to not
be all inspired when he walks into a
room he's just he's so suave and Johnny
and I had a very instant kind of
brother-sister sort of relationship and
we found pickering really funny it's
lovely when you can feel so safe with
somebody that you know that you can act
like try absolutely anything and they'll
go with you on it so every take was
really different and I was really fun
first bad date I was on a date that
wasn't a date once and that sucked like
that was awful I was just like I was
convinced it was a day I was so excited
about it and I think at the end of it he
like punched my arm was like I'm so glad
you're my friend nothing me two men yeah
this is this is great so I'm it was my
first bad non-date
this has been so much fun even though
I'm mildly embarrassed now that Emma
comes out on March 6th so please check
it out cuz that's actually really good
fun I
[Music]